for many parents having a child with a
severe food allergy
means living with the fear that one
mistake could be a life-threatening
experience
in today's health watch denise tells us
about a natural approach
to managing allergies denise yeah
kirsten it's a holistic approach that's
really making a difference in fact so
far more than 500 children
have been successfully treated and it is
so effective
there's now a waiting list to be part of
this program a mother of three nicole
zoo for instance never thought her kids
could eat ice cream there's dairy in
there there's nuts
all of her children had battled
life-threatening food and environmental
allergies
causing multiple trips to the er they
also have severe eczema
well that's when she ran out of medical
options and she found her way to amy
tierringer's allergy release technique
now she
identifies which toxins are creating
stress then she rebalances the gut
bacteria she uses probiotics
in order to reset what's really an
overactive immune system
so we're working on strengthening and
supporting the immune system
calming the anxiety response and then we
slowly and safely
introduce the food so that in about a
three month period
the child is able to eat that food
freely
that amazing terranger is preparing for
a large-scale medical study of her work
the results are really promising she
claims she's already cured more than 500
children so this is
interesting the family profiled in that
story now has their allergies so under
control
they were able to adopt a puppy
something they never thought would be
possible for their family
they have a long waiting list and
they've trained dozens of other
practitioners on the east coast to try
and expand this program
kristin